c'est inouï des fans de toutes les
générations
fabienne thibeault est révélée au grand
public en 1979 avec starmania
depuis 40 ans le public répond toujours
présent j'écoute vraiment ça tout le
temps vraiment mais en bout que je
l'écouté je sais pas combien de fois du
coup après j'ai acheté l'album vinyle
album le spectacle après j'ai écouté
aussi les autres les albums solos de
fabienne thibeault on est toujours très
heureux de la retrouver
je ne suis une grande admiratrice de
starmania j'ai vu pratiquement toutes
les versions sauf la première mesure
j'étais pas j'étais toute petite et une
grande admiratrice de michel berger la
première serveuse automate publie un
ouvrage mon starmania
elle y confie à l'aide d'un thé
rencontres faites lors de cette tournée
d'une trentaine de dates passer auprès
de luc plamondon et michel berger et
vaniel balavoine
j'ai voulu confier ou en juin celle
qu'il ne voit pas quand ils viennent au
spectacle ou qu'ils écoutent le disque
ce qui se passe il est un petit peu
mystérieux en fait j'étais un petit peu
le mystère de la création d'une amicale
du nombre cynique et qui parfois
surprenante parce qu'on ne sait pas
comment ça se passe
une séance de dédicaces organisée par
bernard delattre l'ancien journaliste et
auteure yvelinois fabienne thibeault a
préfacé son dernier ouvrage
j'y croyais pas trop je me suis je suis
parce que ce serait bien puis je parle
d'elle dans dans le livre parce que dans
le livre il ya beaucoup de références à
la la musique québécoise de ces années
là il rencontre avec le public qui aura
une suite fabienne thibeault sera aussi
présente au salon du livre d'elancourt
le 29 novembre prochain